[Music]
we're so happy for you take me back to
that moment are you nervous I think the
most nervous time for me was asking her
father for her hand in marriage I did it
the traditional way
I was nervous call him up and you're
like hey I need to ask you know in
person in person what was your first
thought you guys are just having a fun
vacay and you're like okay cute little
time and then we're literally in Aspen
Skiing on the mountain so it was just a
huge surprise and so romantic and one of
the most exciting days of my life it was
inspired by her mother's engagement ring
I know she's very family-oriented and an
old fashioned so we just designed a
pear-shaped ring that was good enough
for Paris Hilton I just have never felt
happier in my life my feel like I'm
glowing and just feel I don't know like
a woman just like an adult like I don't
know it's like my life is finally just
starting
what is it that you love about I think
she's one of the most intellectual women
I've ever met I think the better
question is what don't you like and
that's there's nothing
[Music]